to most of us the Cova 19 pandemic may
seem like something shockingly new but
America has been here before in 1918
when the Spanish flu struck and more
than a century before that when yellow
fever ravaged one of our largest cities
in that crisis as in this one medical
professionals were saving lives
including one doctor who played another
key role helping give birth to this
nation his story is told in the book
rush by author Steven freed Benjamin
Rush was first of all sort of the
founding father that people haven't
found yet this is the good dr. rush but
author Steven free thinks it's high time
America did he had very quietly helped
write the proclamation that set off the
Boston Tea Party he had written one of
the first major abolition writings
within two years of the Continental
Congress coming to Philadelphia he was
in the Continental Congress and he was
signing the Declaration of Independence
at the age of thirty freed spent five
years writing the biography on Benjamin
Rush this is Benjamin Rush's handwritten
autobiography at his disposal Russia's
own autobiography and Diaries housed at
the American Philosophical Society in
Philadelphia curated by Charles Griffin
Stein about the Year 1774 a certain
Thomas Paine arrived in Philadelphia so
this is rush beginning to tell the story
of how he met Thomas Paine who was just
a local writer they talked about writing
about independence which rush considered
to be a very dangerous thing to even
write the word independence so he
actually decided that he would encourage
like this one the account of your
sister's illness and danger contained in
your letter of last night has greatly
disturbed me it was 1793 and yellow
fever was ravaging Philadelphia much
like Kove at 19 today ten percent of the
city's population died in just three
months but like our health care workers
today while rush sent his family away to
safety he stayed to treat the sick not
only are they in the middle of an
epidemic but rush works from his home
and they are treating all these people
in their house so their house is like a
hospital I mean the death was just
incomprehensible just like today's
pandemic the best treatment was unclear
and the disease caused the deepening of
political rifts between two founding
fathers with Russian Alexander Hamilton
a prominent federalist on different
sides when Alexander Hamilton said he
had yellow fever Thomas Jefferson said
he probably didn't and that when when
Hamilton said that he was cured and he
was cured by a doctor different than
Rush and then Hamilton made fun of
Russia's treatment the african-americans
who stayed interestingly initially they
were told by Rush that they were less
likely to get the disease because the
medical books of the day said that they
learned very quickly that wasn't true
and they continued to stay because they
were there to be of service
Russia's legacy may have been marred
because he used medical treatments that
are now discredited like bloodletting
which involved removing a patient's
blood to cure ailments he gets judged as
a doctor when in fact his main role in
life was about being a politician a
philosopher a writer and his ideas about
medical education are much more
important than whether we still use
bloodletting also important the company
rush kept he often dined here at City
Tavern with his much more famous
co-conspirators under British rule John
Adams Thomas Jefferson even George
Washington they were aware that in
theory they were committing treason but
they also didn't respect the government
anymore they wouldn't have their own
government and they were very brave
but for all of his influence rush has
not found celebrity the way some other
founding fathers have lend I'm well
written Hamilton about rush about right
absolutely rush was a much better more
interesting person than Hamilton I
[Music]
understand why manual a New Yorker was
interested in Hamilton who was the only
really significant New Yorker in the
revolution but if he wants to come back
to do rush rush was so much a part of
the helping of the founding of the black
church in America that he could do rush
in gospel what I found out in looking at
not only his writing but what happened
after he died is that there was a
concerted effort to keep what was most
interesting about rush from the public
why well John Adams and Thomas Jefferson
had written rush some of the most
incredibly personal letters they ever
shared with any of them hundreds of them
rush was kind of the founding father who
knew too much his legacy was sort of
slowly quashed but Russia's legacy does
thrive here in Philadelphia's
Pennsylvania Hospital this is the
amphitheater this is the surgical
amphitheater Rush came in to make sure
that there was more space for Mayo
treatment of mental illness
Russia's passion was personal his son
John descended into mental illness after
killing his best friend in a duel and
was treated here for decades late in his
life rush wrote another public letter
saying these are the things we need to
do dramatically improve care for the
mentally ill he brought the fact that
John was there into the public into the
newspapers because he was so intent on
advocating for the rights of the
mentally ill for their diagnosis for
their dignity for Steven freed
resurrecting the most significant
founding father we've never heard of is
more relevant now than ever there's a
reason they used the phrase more perfect
union no one thought it was perfect and
part of what I love about Russia's
writing is really trying to point out
the things about America they're gonna
be hard racial prejudice
having science and religion live
together having liberty and good
government live together he wrote about
these things in a way that I think is
still thoughtful today and makes you
realize that these issues are hardwired
into the American experiment which we
are still in if ever there was a
Renaissance man Benjamin Rush was it
there is so much more about this guy
this should be talked about and used to
read the book I will fascinating story
Michelle and now I want to see rush on
Broadway as well really really good
you